there's a few strike going on now the
certain excite kids in the street is hit
going round to head out going all the
time
[Music]
even just going to Mosel you knew on
that day somebody would become very near
to dying
[Music]
we're getting nearer and nearer nearer
to the final areas which is the old city
of Mosul
with very very intense fighting a very
very built our barracks with massive
city
[Music]
[Applause]
I've cleared this was gonna be really
really tough not least because you're
fighting an opponent who wants to die
which is a sort of slightly different
dynamic to any other war I've done I
knew is gonna be dangerous
I knew it was gonna be chaotic I just
didn't realize quite how quickly it can
change from a relatively comfortable
everything's fine situation to in an
instant just complete madness Islamic
state would either push forward with
suicide bombers come by foot and move
just literally from the house the house
I feel like we've established frontlines
and the enemy is there and then all of
sudden they were there they're over
there and even worse that they might
just be coming in from behind you you
found yourself going forward with one
unit and realizing that actually we've
gone past three sets of Islamic state
units which are in the house next door
change very very quickly and by that
time it can be too late for some people
I think everyone thought that the Iraqi
army was absolutely incapable of this to
be honest
this was an army 50,000 soldiers this
had fled in front and I took 5,000
Islamic state fighters
they clearly been retrained 33 armed
desert and they seem to have got a
backbone that they had never had before
if I'm honest or scared the whole time
constantly ratcheting it up and you're
shunned of getting a lid on it and so
you don't just turn up in its chaos the
chaos increases gradually as you drive
in
it was a difficult choice making
decisions as to whether today we go
forward or not in this particular
instance he was one of those days where
we got up very early in the morning five
or six that was the first move towards
the old town we pulled over
it was really horrible cold wet morning
in Missoula and we've gone forward to a
place where we could hear things
happening in the distance but we weren't
under any direct threat
people were relaxed with fires and
cooking food and stuff on that so there
was any feeling of imminent threat there
my name is Maxim Hawks Araki my country
in a snipe that came past and said I can
take you up to the front if you like and
I was sort of thinking I think I said to
the guys like I really this is a really
bad idea that was just just don't fancy
this today it's not it's not good
Stewart actually hesitates it he wasn't
sure they had another he'll come flap
and then came back and said how about we
just nip up the road and we'll come back
that's the everyone geared up and got
all their gear honestly like I can't
just let you go he has made the decision
that if I was happy to go our security I
was happy to go and I'll produce I was
happy to go then he has part of the team
should go so he agreed then we all went
together where we running to that tight
let me get that so we'll see what's
going on anything right now you have to
run so you just like it yeah
we arrived and those thinkin out the way
get out the way we thinking like we're
being attacked for something it wasn't
it was a bunch of guys had got a drove
which you know you buy in a sort of
drone shop or whatever not particularly
sophisticated drone and they put loads
of grenades on it and the soldier was
saying like out of the way because these
grenades always falling off there's a
big truck like a camper van but it's
armor plated and that was a control
centre for the guide for the drone so
they've got the cameras on that so I
went in to film the screen hoping to
capture the moment where the bombs
dropped and landed on a target
I see a digger coming from behind
sounded like a metal grinding sound like
a vehicle hitting another vehicle and
continuing driving like a sort of slow
car crash then I just heard a shout and
I look around and all I could see was
soldiers running in every direction and
I stepped back out of the truck and I
realized that they were all running and
people were actually hitting the ground
so it's like thinking so there's either
something coming or something that
something's happening remember seeing
guys running and hearing shouting it
sure came in it was that split-second
decision do we stay here or do we go
we're normal six-packs just come down he
was a month I just landed in between us
you can see the whole place is covered
in smoke
they got yeah he's still running still
roughing haste good everyone's good what
was that
and actually what was funny was people
were talking about say are you okay but
it was like a question you okay it's
like are you actually okay and I
remember feeling my hands and thinking
wow I've actually every bits here it's
funny because the moment that happens
there's a moment of I'm alive
so then immediately thinks your
colleagues are they okay and Stuart was
there with me he was fine and then
really weirdly I just had pop into my
head I should be a rugby practice for my
sons so this shouldn't be here I should
be somewhere else anywhere but here and
then just flip back into right dear job
you hear focus do what you're doing
we open the door and this kind of stuff
and a soldiers running and we get out
and it's going absolutely crazy
my car security guy comes running he
told me later that he thought he was
coming to find about what was left it
was not not if we had survived what
that was a large armored digger that was
in between us an explosion I think a
proximity to he really should have been
dead
it's firing coming in now from two sides
to be run behind this firewall and then
somebody shouted there's a sniper so you
go from worrying about that to the next
thing not only are they under attack
that the weapons that are inside the
various Humvees etc can't start cooking
office is what it's called actually the
weapons himself start firing in the heat
of the fire
the injured are now being pulled out who
brought it toward us and there's loads
of it we still don't know how many
people died there but it was a lot I
think it's 20 or 30 and the initial
thing probably at least double that when
it came to the injuries after make me
feel going for me doing my job that
mechanism of focusing framing recording
helps me get past the fear because I've
got something to focus on
that was as chaotic as a situation as
I've ever been in and it was my
experience just focus on what you're
here to do to try and capture some
images and some sound and what's
happening around you that's what it is
do man
I couldn't focus and I couldn't get the
shot still enough to use it and he said
that you're ready and I said I'm shaking
I'm shaking and shaking and I was
purposely saying out loud to myself to
say your body's doing that it's
perfectly normal but just kind of get
used to it don't worry about it this is
gonna happen and then within a few
seconds it's just kind of calm down okay
okay okay ready and he did it and he got
the first time as he always does you see
the people are injured is pre-k or two
that's beer definitely under attack now
sniper superior in numbers position
attack clearly in a certain amount of
shock and I still trying to defend
themselves it's pretty tough
[Music]
and it was getting so intense we had to
Scrabble to another section
you're right
found ourselves in this compound there's
a huge spike going on now the septic
cycle is in the street let's hit the
plane rounds I had out going all the
time so just trying to control this
would basically hiding in rubble map
trying to find a way to get out of here
it's the moments impossible to move too
much action by this point the call had
gone to the helicopters to come and
protect them
when all is lost you might as well be
blowin up and some of you might survive
because one thing's for certain the
enemy is in the continued amongst you
already
a helicopter gunships are not firing
into everywhere where we are
tonight as this massive terror then
because they're gonna shoot anything
that moves because they've been ordered
to do so that was the scariest point
because you're thinking if we don't have
those guys to defend us we didn't have
soldiers with this but your thoughts
then it's not going to I don't want to
be captured by these guys because they
just cut my head off on the internet and
I don't want that
I hit the defenders but we were so close
to where we think the bad guys were my
famous takers for people that they're
shooting him
thankfully they decided not to shoot us
I think that I think they knew that we
had guys with radios but it was very
nerve-racking we stay there for about I
felt like forever I couldn't even tell
you how long it was quite a long time
and then it did intensity of fighting
was getting worse not better so we
decided to scout around and try and get
to the river
one of the soldiers might have looked
down there and he basically signaled to
another soldier that he saw there was
another Iraqi soldier I'm going to come
over here with some people and they're a
few soldiers said no we don't know who
you want and get back it's like no no no
seriously we're not just let me stay but
we don't know who you are in fact it's
worse your foreigners we have one choice
which is to head back to where the
explosion happened so we ended up going
background and then scooting over a few
walls and through a couple of buildings
worrying about IEDs all the way and then
turned up literally next to where the
bomb had gone off
it's still on fine you can see the
remnants that it look reading back
there's just chaos I mean you can see
any couldn't see any bodies or anything
I'm assuming that the nature the
explosion it was just incinerated a lot
waters around here it was clear that
there had been a really severe blast
you could see just the frame of the
vehicle that blew up next to the tank
it was just charred still on fire in
places
it did make me feel very lucky because
that was the first time I realized quite
how big it was
to see the scale of the blast the
devastation around it the destruction
that it caused we suddenly realized how
severe and how cats a shop in that
explosion was to anybody close to it we
then made a decision that we couldn't
stay there any long
and I remember actually as we were
running out and that member sent isn't
it tonight I did say I had a bad idea it
was like one of those ones away everyone
did genuinely laugh within minutes
social media has the attack filmed by an
Islamic state drove and it shows this
truck coming through the lines hits into
another LV
and then drives past our truck
in explodes and the mushroom cloud is
absolutely enormous and they're looking
at nation Queen did that that is an hour
bomb that really showed the scale of it
because it felt bad when we felt it I
assumed it was awful when we saw it from
when we returned to the site and then to
see it from above afterwards it was it's
quite breathtaking actually it was made
me feel sick maybe realize a lot of
people died there they showed their
tactics really really well
the guy had basically come from behind
our lines of the crunching noise that I
heard was him pushing past Humvees to
get to the tank yeah I know you realized
we get a sense of the enormity of it and
how lucky we were because could very
easily at that that there yeah that was
just luck I mean shot at many times and
actually properly targeted so this
wasn't personal but it's just the size
of the bomb I mean I think the chance of
surviving that they flip of the coin
toss a spoon
[Music]
as a team making that decision at that
time we decided together whether it's
safe or not that's what comes back from
that experience for me is that we went
there together who made the decision it
was the wrong decision in hindsight but
we made it together and therefore I
can't be mad at anybody I can't be upset
about that in the future it has to be
the same it has to be that we're all
comfortable doing together and making
those decisions together and taking
those risks together